what does this child's game teach us
about the history of writing something
basic but incredibly inventive you
learned how to write with symbols that
stand for words logographs and you saw
just how many logographs you need to
write well logographs for everything
under the Sun and the moon including the
Sun in the moon but isn't this getting
impractical do we really need a symbol
for every word surely the madness can't
go on forever say hello to this smart
rogue who's about to solve your problem
with an innocent mistake his father has
been counting sheep literally and he
just asked his son to record a measly
line in his budget ten sheep for uncle
the son writes the 10 and the logograph
for sheep but uncle he pauses and
scratches his head eager to play with
his friends he writes the character for
ankle 10 sheep ankle he hurries away
without a second thought
but don't take his invention lightly if
you've ever played fill in the blank or
guessing games where you have to sound
out picture words you've seen and use
this principle for yourself but it's not
just for quirky puzzles with funny
solutions the name for this is another
major moment in the history of writing
um the name for this is is rebus this
familiar language game lets you look
beyond the meaning of a character and
use it simply for its sound son sounds
like son and by extension perhaps soon
and sone logographs like the symbol for
son could already be read as words now
with the rebus principle in your pocket
logographs can also be read as sounds
this isn't just useful for getting
ancient uncle his ancient sheep once
Aztec city planners finished building
their stunning capital in the middle of
a lake the Venice of the new world
Tenochtitlan their scribes needed a way
to write its name they've been using
what amounts to basic picture writing
since Tenochtitlan has a stone Tay and a
cactus no chilli its natural to write it
with two fairly obvious glyphs then
these become not just symbols meaning
cactus and stone but symbols for the
noises
inaudible on making them just as much
rebus fun as those puzzles you solved as
a kid and now you know the name for
those you also know why there's a cactus
on top of a stone in Mexico's flag it's
not just for show
howlite does the sound-alike
pronunciation have to be which sounds
can we chop off pit the Egyptians
against the Sumerians one more time
Egyptian hieroglyphs cut off the initial
consonant or less often two or three
consonants from the original word
Sumerians on the other hand with their
cuneiform take whole syllables these two
paths don't just add some local flavor
Reba sing out consonants doesn't just
impact ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs it
leaves a legacy for later spin-offs the
mentality that these are either read as
logographs
or they stand for consonants Kanaya form
leaves a different legacy completely
unrelated languages will spend thousands
of years of borrowing and reborrowing
cuneiform to write their own words but
each time the symbols are read as
logographs or as syllables flexibility
is key here look at this Egyptian
hieroglyph it can be read as the
logograph or mouth gray or is the
consonant or this character could be
read as the logograph meaning house or
it could stand for the consonant / the
two consonants in the Egyptian word
conveniently in Egyptian the little / e
below lets you know when it's appear
logograph the rebus discovery brings up
a tension between meaning and sound is
writing phonetic or semantics is it
about encoding the meaning of words or
encoding speech sounds the old
logographs were fundamentally a meaning
writing system sure this sounds like rey
in egyptian but what's crucial is that
this is a local graph for the word
meaning mouth rebus writing takes a big
step towards sound writing this will
come to stand for the consonant order
regardless of meaning it may come as a
surprise but once discovered sound
writing doesn't ask meaning writing not
at all indeed early writers notice that
phonetic writing brings up a problem a
problem you probably missed because of
your comfort with sound writing a
problem that meaning writing can solve
brace yourself history because
logographs are
about to make a comeback
you